[Music]
good afternoon everyone welcome to the
last session of the first day of next
hope you guys have had a good time and I
hope you enjoy that this session for for
our last last one of the day I am Peter
mark bear ward I'm the head of migration
architecture here at Google they said in
New York I'm gonna be working with I'm
gonna be speaking with beg your pardon
ray hwang jeff allen and more gantt a
pelt and what we're gonna do is go over
cloud foundation and how to automate
that foundation in the cloud and what
that is is a cloud foundation is what
you need to create before you move or
create a single compute resource in the
cloud it's what you need to make sure
everything's working properly I like to
use the analogy of a house because I
think it really kind of matches up what
you're doing in the cloud it's uh if you
think about it the cloud foundation is
what you need before you start putting
in windows putting in doors painting all
these things you need a solid foundation
you need plumbing you need wiring before
you want before you build a house that's
solid and what we want to do is really
go over what will make your house in the
cloud solid so as you can probably guess
from my title I work with a lot of
customers who are moving to GCP and when
I work with these customers we follow a
really relatively prescriptive process
and the reason we do this is because it
works it probably doesn't seem
particularly different from things
you've seen at other companies but
consistency around investing in our
customers in this plan allows us to do
what we do over and over and over again
and repeat that success so when we first
engage with customers we come in we
figure out what you've got we assess the
challenges limitations of the systems
that you have today and find out what
your goals and hopes and plans and
requirements are for the future and this
is how we get and when we plan what
you're going to migrate this is before
anything is done in GCP this is just a
conversation between us
and our customers after that we build
the foundation we design how we are
going to take the solution and
technologies available in Google cloud
and connect them to the problems and
environments and applications that you
have today and then we establish a place
to build all of those applications in a
secure and agile manner and then we help
you deploy that we're never going to go
away so we start working together on a
deployment plan to make sure it's
successful to make sure we follow
through with the things that we we plan
together that we discuss together that
we created in the foundation together
and make sure that you have access to
technical resources on our side so that
those systems work how they're supposed
to and we work through performance we
work through management we work through
operations of all that and then we're
still not done then we start talking
about optimization we start looking at
what are the long term plans what could
you do with what you have where would
you like to improve what is not working
as well as you would like to what are
the new things that you would like to
try out that you haven't had a chance to
try out and this is a process that
continues as our relationship with you
continues this is not something that
happens and then we're done we keep on
working with you and so the optimization
is the last step but it is a last step
that is ongoing throughout our
relationship with our customers so today
though we are just gonna focus on that
second step on the foundation when I
engage with customers I tend to harp on
this quite a bit because I feel like a
solid foundation really gives you the
flexibility and possibility to have a
successful migration and that requires
doing a lot of that work upfront and so
while we're just gonna focus on the
foundation in this session there are a
lot of other sessions happening at NEX
that you can attend that are going to
cover different aspects of kind of the
overall migration journey and we've got
a few suggestions at the end of this
session that you might be interested in
so let's get to it what we're gonna
cover today is the kind of the minut
detail of how we're going to build out a
foundation we're going to cover identity
and organization in the cloud and then
once you have that part of the
foundation then you start adding on to
that Network and security
and so these are the kind of the very
core important parts of your foundation
this is what you need to have a again
what I said the secure and agile place
for applications to reside and then what
we're going to do is once we've covered
all that we're going to show you how you
could automate that entire process and
have it spun up in a repeatable way with
code that you can check in that you can
version that you can build on and have a
foundation no cloud that you can
automate so with that I'd like to hand
it off to my colleague Ray Wang who will
discuss identity and organization thank
you management as Peter mark just said
identity organization and access
policies are the first steps to your GCP
migration so let's walk through them now
you want to make sure that the data and
resources you have on GCP a very secure
so for anybody to access them first they
have to be authenticated and authorized
authentication authorization working
hand handing hinge pretty much like your
passport and visa authentication proves
who you are and authorization proves
what you have access to
they also after known as the identity
and access management in I am so for you
to authenticate toutaku GCP you have to
have an identity that's understood by
GCP the same identity that you also use
to access Gmail and Doc's can be used to
access TCP api's as well and if you are
an enterprise customer you need to do
more to actually manage and track the
identities and if you're looking for an
IDP one great option here is to use
cloud identity cloud and India gives you
a central place to create and curate and
manage the credentials of a company if
you're DCP only customer you can take
advantage of cloud identities without
having to sign up to G suite now if you
use car identities because Google
manages your logging you get the benefit
of secure logging
Password Reset session device tracking
and can know where and when people have
laughing and because google tracks the
logins google can't detect suspicious
activities and it can be configured to
alert you when they happen so cloud and
she is a great option if you're a pro in
a cloud company don't have an existing
IDP you're looking for a simple solution
but what if you're already having vested
in an IDP and you have a process that
works for you you want to continue to
use you can continue to use your your
existing IDP with GCP via Federation and
single sign-on when single sign-on SSO
is configured whenever a user come your
one of your identities comes to DCP they
will be redirected to your IDP for
authentication and because it's it's
pretty common that your user has already
being authenticated in your own system
that means they will get instant access
to DCP api's so for SSO to work the
other thing that needs to exist is the
users that you read our attitude to tcp
they need to have the accounts that's
known to Google and they already exist
in Google to help with that we have a
tool Cochise EDS Google cloud directory
sync that will help you to out americaís
sync our of your users and groups into
Google using Federation with SSO is a
very common configuration used by most
of our largest customers with some
syncing up to a few hundred thousand
accounts so how do you set it up well
setting up SSO is very simple there's
three links to your existing identity
system and SSO is built on top of sam'l
- as some of you might know some o2 is
the secure industry protocol for
exchanging user credentials and the user
assertion we care about here is the
username now SEMO - also offers the
option to digitally sign information to
prevent tampering to do that you can
provide the information on the digital
certificate used to verify your
signature when you do that you can make
sure that all the information coming
through SSO is indeed coming from you
and has not been tampered with and what
if your system does not support some o2
while you can also use one
one of those third-party options such as
peeing a doctor to bridge the gap here
so so once you use cloud and she whether
you know as your own IDP or whether as a
Federation tool you also get access to
other advanced features that are offered
on top of GCP one such example is beyond
corp beyond corp is an enterprise-grade
security model that's based on top of
the six years of learning from building
zero trust network at Google and
combined with the Best of Breed
ideas and practices front industry and
now BM Corp is available to you as a GCP
service called IDP identity aware proxy
using IDP your administrators can define
which users or groups can in under which
context such as you know networking
secure device can access the
applications you have that are running
on top of GCP as well so with all these
benefits how do you get cloud identity
it's fairly simple to you as a tcp
customer you go to the GCP cloud console
you click on identity here you see a
page and which has links to all kinds of
documentation you can click navigate to
manage your users and groups Google
admin console and if you click on a sign
up button it will take you through a
guided flow to sign up for cloud energy
for your company's domain at the end of
this Rufus flow you also a GC
organization will automatically be
provisioned for your cloud entity domain
we'll talk more about Ana's ations a
little later and here you also have the
option to go through guided flows to set
up the rest of your your organization
related stuff such as I am organization
policies and billing for a company so
once you have you know Federation's you
sign up for our cloud identity you have
Federation set up your users and groups
will be synced into Google and we talked
about why user drink pardon but why do
you need to use groups so we all know
that in a large enterprise you might
have you know thousands or even tens of
thousands of users it will be really
cumbersome if you have to manage each
individual one of their excess so
instead we'll want to manage at the
group level
groups provide a level of abstraction
between your users and the resources
they need to access so let's take an
example if you have a set up team they
need the the secure the security admin
role an organization so they can
configure the security settings for
organization and that team has ten
people so what you want to do is to
create a group have these team members
join a group and then assign a group
security aming role on your organization
now if after that you have new members
joining a group all you have to do is to
add a user to a group you don't have to
go and assign the user and give it the
permissions they need on different
resources they are automatically inherit
what a group has what about if the
team's job function changes now they
also need the log of URL so that they
can watch for you know critical adding
setting changes all you need to do is to
assign the log view or row to the second
team group on your organisation again
you won't have to go and change the
setting for the individual users you can
manage groups either through you know
cloud entity or in your own IDP by
Federation but in either case you want
to make sure that you safeguard your
group membership by setting additional
policies such as the policy to prevent
outside identities from joining your
company's domain groups or the
permissions and who is able to create
new groups of their own so we talked
about users and groups there is a third
type of identity that's often used with
GCP which service accounts so unlike
users groups which are identity for
human beings your service accounts are
the identities for your animations and
programs that are running on top of GCP
your users can type the username
password to log in the service counts is
not going to sit in front of a screen
type so instead they use keys to
authenticate when I'm a service account
keys can be created for each service
account and since using these keys you
basically are granting people access to
your sensitive data and resources you
want to make sure that your safeguard
keys if you're running applications on
top of Google with you know GAE or GC or
GAE will keep your key secure and then
automatically rotate them every few
hours so that way you don't have to
download his and you don't have to risk
losing your leaking your keys what if
you run applications
elsewhere in a hybrid environment that
happens quite often well you can't you
can download the keys to be used from
applications the application can access
GCP however here you really need to be
careful about where you store those keys
they give access to sensitive data so
you want to store them in a secure
service such as maybe about and what you
don't want to do is just to store them
in plaintext on github the other
interesting about service account is
that it's not only an identity it's also
a resource so when you have a VM that's
running as a service account here the
service account is acting as the
identity the VM you assume the service
account identity to get access to
resources and ApS Harvard see the same
time you also want to be able to control
which users which VMs are able to assume
this identity so here the service
account acts as a resource and you can
grant access to the service account via
granting the service the service account
Act has Rho now a very common way of
using service account is with GC VMs
when use of his account to to run GC VMs
you can sub partition the other VMs in a
project into different components with
different identities for example if you
have one component that needs to access
a GCS bucket in a different component
that needs to access a bigquery data set
you can assign each one a different
identity and then grant each identity
the least privilege required you can
change the service count on VM without
having to restart a VM and later on in
the network section we're going to talk
about how to use these attributes of the
service counts to create more secure
firewall rules so once you have your
identity domain the identities domain
set up with GCP an organization is
automatically created for you the GCP
organization is the root node for all
the resources in your company so R of
your VMs buckets in the projects and so
on live under the organization there's a
wonderful relationship between the
identity domain and the GCP organization
and using this relationship we're able
to enforce rules such that other
projects and the resources that are
created by your company's employees will
belong to your organization node and
this ensures that there's no more
gardening's or hidden projects the
central army will have control and
visibility to everything so more about a
research hierarchy well we talked about
you don't want to manage individual
users you also don't want to managing
the video VMS and storage objects right
you can end up with thousands of the
main in in case of objects millions of
them there cattle not pets
so to scare out operation you want to be
able to run operations and set policies
on a group level and the most common way
of grouping resources in GCP is through
the resource hierarchy at the bottom
level you have your VMs and storage
objects and then packets about that you
have projects projects the most basic
unit for ownership and policies in in
GCP they often used to simulate a team
or environment or service and about
projects you have folders the
hierarchical and they can be used to
model your departments or organization
units and then above the folders you
have the organizational which is again
here root node so once you have set up
your research hierarchy it makes a lot
of the organization-wide management
tasks much simpler for example you can
control who and company is not allowed
to start new projects and create
additional resources you can do so by
assigning the project creator role at
each of the levels in hierarchy you can
also automate the building of an
inventory of your research and policies
by programmatically traversing through
the arc the folders and projects and the
resources and so on another common
practice is to assign a service account
the the permissions and the org level so
the service count can go and patrol that
the configurations in your organization
to enforce compliance and in fact this
is what the Google Google's own security
team to us to manage our Google account
tcp resources as well so research
hierarchy is great it defines a very
strict ownership hierarchy and it gives
you policy inheritance but there many
times you also need to define other
relationships that are outside of the
hierarchy for example we can have two
departments you know you have storefront
team and our inventory service each of
which can have
a production environment versus a dev
testing environment how do you define
these environments while common way of
doing that is by labels labels are key
value pairs that are user defined and
can be attached to resources so in this
case you can assign environment equal to
no progress especially F to the
different projects in the three
different departments once you have
assigned labels you can search for
resources based on your labels and
labels also included in painting export
so you can use that to do cost
aggregation for different efforts
initiatives so once we have the research
hierarchy and labels we can also define
you know hierarchical policies some
examples Here I am
identity access management organization
policies which is about constraining the
configurations in a company and
hierarchical quota so I am is the policy
that allows you to tell who can do what
on which resources the who part refers
to identities and the research part can
be defined by either individual
resources like vm's or pockets or
hierarchy hierarchical notes such as
projects and folders they can do what
part in the middle is defined by an IM
role and I am row after maps to a job
function for example if you are the
instance at being 14 and it is it is
constructed as a group of permissions so
here if you need to manage other
instances for Department you need to be
able to you know get in this term start
and stop them and so on
so we group have these permissions
together and make them an iamb role in
this example here you can see that we
are signing the instance admin role to a
number of users
project a which means these users can
then use the road to manage to run
operations out instances in this project
now GCP ships out of the box over a
hundred curate heroes that have been
built for you hopefully we mapped you a
lot of your job functions but if you
need more you can also build custom
roles to specifically tailor roles that
are that match your business needs so
another new capability to I am that
we're gonna be launching in the next few
days this is a sneak preview is I am
conditions
I am condition
allow you to further restrict the
success that I am grants by additional
either client or resource attributes so
for example I can assign Peter mark
storage add me a bucket but with the
condition that he can only access the
objects that match a particular prefix
so you can grant sub bucket level I am
that way you can also use conditions to
do contact aware access for example you
can assign permission to access
particularly sensitive resources but
only when the client traffic is coming
from a trusted network maybe a company's
VPN and later in the network section we
also going to talk about how to use
contact aware with your VPC to set the
boundary at organization level as well
another common use of conditions is to
set time bound access policies so you
can grant temporary access and have it
out of expire when time is up this is
often used for example if you're an
admin for the break glass situation or
to time with their teams and
connotations so I am policy focuses on
the I on the identity differentiates
access based on who you are it's sibling
organization policy allows the admin to
set secure configuration constraints for
the organization it differentiates based
on resources and applies to all the
identities to access a particular
resource organization constraints can be
set on the org level and it will be
inherited into off the projects and
resources underneath and then can also
be either augmented or overridden on the
other organization level such as folders
and projects so here are some examples
of the organization policy that are
available today you can for example
limit the usage of VM nested
virtualization or external IP serial
port you can also use it to control your
IM policies for example preventing
external identities from being added to
the excess of your company's resources
or prevent the creation of service
accounts or keys in a particular project
so let's look at one of the movie one of
them in more details the restricted VM
trusted image policy so if you use GC
you Mary be aware of the GC image
sharing feature
which allows you to curate your images
under one project and share with the
other VM seeing any other projects
now once you've set up the corresponding
arc policies you can whitelist a set of
projects hosting the VMS that are
allowed to be used as safe for your
organization
for example you can limit it to only the
VMS that are published by Google or you
only the projects containing the ends
that have been fully tested and blessed
by a security team and once you have
configured this policy the next time
your developers come and tries to spin
VM they will only be a be able to choose
from these safe images that you have
defined via policy okay so that was a
lot let's put them together and look at
an end to an example of how to configure
identities organization access policies
for an enterprise company so if you run
an enterprise company you probably have
multiple levels of organizations that
are built up over the years in this day
and age you probably care about security
and privacy and separation of duty and
you likely also already have existing
on-prem assets and processes that your
cloud deployments need to be able to
work with so this is a typical setup you
might have your on-prem out app system
hosting identities and have federates
them into Google via cloud identity and
an organization now will be set up to
match your cloud identity account and
will give your admins central visibility
and control of Aria resources
organization policies can be set up to
prevent unsafe configurations for any
organization and protect compliance and
security requirements and it is often
that procurement decisions are made at
the org level essentially right instead
of every developer deciding what use on
their own and then resource provisioning
as well as major configuration changes
are driven through existing processes
such as a ticketing system or CI CD
pipeline now the benefit of doing that
is that your developers then will need
to have direct access to the actual
resources especially in production
environment instead they can request to
that other changes be driven through
existing you know automated workflows
and everything will leave a trace
through your get repo your CI CD
pipeline and then you can set up your
folders and projects to model your teams
and departments so that they can have
very separate policies as well as
different cost allocation so if you have
your HR department with their apps and
your stuff around Department with their
apps you can make sure that they they
can each get very different you know
access levels and compliance policies
and when you when it comes to billing
time you can also figure out how much
each department has spent so that was a
quick tour through setting up identities
organization access policies for
organization another important step in a
migration will be figuring out how to
configure our network settings so for
that let's welcome on stage Jeff Allen
hi I'm Jeff Allen I'm a Solutions
Architect here at Google cloud and what
we're going to talk about is building on
this conversation of identity and
organization talk about some of the
foundations and some of the foundational
decisions we need to make in the area of
network and security focusing really on
three primary topics the topology the
structure in the layout of our network
as well as network connectivity as we
design this network to interact with
other systems of how are we going to
create that connectivity and in regards
to security how are we going to do
access control and auditing and have
visibility into what's going on in those
environments so let's start this
topology discussion by looking at the
Google cloud global network now you may
have seen this kind of depiction before
where we've got all of our region's up
here along with the points of presence
where you can ingress on to the Google
private network and all the lines
connecting the dots are the miles of our
private fiber subsea cables that really
create what differentiates a Google
cloud platform this global network with
very low latency single hop routing
the globe and it's this network which
provides the backbone for your global VP
sees on a Google cloud platform now if
you're interested in this map by the way
I will call out that you can get a copy
of it a poster if you're interested so
if you go to this link this Geena CEO
slash poster in the US will mail you a
free copy of that like wall sized poster
and if you're not you can still download
a high-res image that you could use with
your own large format printer to print
your own poster so if you want to have
one of those hanging on your wall check
out this link so it's within that global
network where we define our VP C's our
virtual private clouds those are the
network environments where we'll launch
our resources but the the resources
themselves tend to exist in what we call
subnets and the subnets aren't global
they're regional resources so we defined
subnets in each region where we intend
to maintain some kind of a compute
presence the the subnets spam the zones
within those regions but here's where we
have some decisions to make about the
topology of our network how big do our
subnets need to be how many subnets do
we need and what regions do we want
those subnets to exist so we've got to
consider our own organization specific
requirements to make those decisions but
there are some best practices to keep in
mind certainly we want to have subnets
available in each of the regions where
we intend our teams to maintain compute
presence they'll need to be sized
appropriately and considering growth but
they're easily extended if you need to
add additional address space to a subnet
our subnets as we consider how to
connect these networks with our other
networks a topic we'll look at
momentarily that relies in general on
having non overlapping IP address ranges
so we want to work within our own
addressing scheme allocate some subnets
some subnets specific to GCP so when you
start connecting this back on Prem you
have non overlapping address spaces to
use and also consider drawing perimeters
around the network segments where you
may want to
which segments have access to the
Internet which segments the segments are
internal only which segments maybe have
some special protection because of some
compliance framework that that were
audited against and divide up our
environment into these segments and
we'll look throughout this presentation
at how we can use network routes and
firewalls to create those those segments
within within our environment another
consideration regarding network topology
is the relationship of our networks to
our project structure ray just showed us
how these projects exist within a
hierarchy of folders in our organization
now the VPC is a resource that's owned
by a project and you certainly can have
your VM instances and your VPC network
in the same project if you choose but in
many cases because of this desire for
separation of duties that's not the way
we tend to see enterprise customers
deploying their their networks there's
this feature called shared VPC which
allows you to define what we call a host
project and that host project is the one
that owns the network this may be owned
by a network security team they define
the network the subnets the firewall
rules and then they share access to what
we call service projects and these
service projects may be owned by the
individual application workload teams
they're allowed to launch resources into
the shared VPC but they themselves don't
have access to configure the network
itself
now that we've got an idea of the way
we're going to lay out our subnets we
want to start thinking about how the
resource is located inside those subnets
are going to interact with other
resources in other networks now in this
scenario we're interested in having our
resources in our V PC subnets
interacting with resources that may
exist in a different VPC maybe within
our same project or a different project
within our org or maybe even a V PC
that's owned by one of our partners it
may not even be ours but if both parties
agree to establish this peering
connection then you can have seamless
routing over the RFC 1918 addresses
between these two V pcs allowing
resources of 1 V PC to communicate with
resources and and the other it's one way
to establish that kind of connectivity
but what if we want the resources in our
V PC to be able to communicate with
Google api's for instance Google Cloud
storage or bigquery we've got instances
and we want them to be able to interact
with those api's well if we provide an
external public routable IP address and
a route through our internet gateway
certainly those instances could egress
to the Internet and interact with the
Google API is but in many cases we don't
want instances egressing directly to the
internet so how can we provide access to
Google api's without internet
connectivity private Google access
provides us the way to do that this is a
subnet level setting and when it's
enabled the instance is in that subnet
even without an external IP address can
aggress through the internet gateway to
specifically the Google API is not the
Internet at large so this is a way of
providing connectivity between your
instances and Google api's without the
instance is actually having full
internet connectivity but in many cases
we do want those instances to be able to
communicate with the Internet and one
way of accomplishing that without
providing each individual instance a
publicly routable IP
is to route their traffic through what
we call an app gateway now in that
gateway is just an instance that itself
is configured with an Internet routable
address bootstrapped to forward traffic
and then you configure that instance as
the next hop address for the Internet
the routing of Internet bound traffic
from within your VPC you could do a
single Matt gateway but in many cases
concerns for resiliency and greater
bandwidth would have us deployed
multiple Matt gateways like we see here
where we might deploy 3.not gateways one
in each zone within the region where
where our subnet exists each of these
Matt gateways is deployed in a managed
instance group with health checks so
that there'll be health checked and if
this health checks start to fail that
instance will be replaced and
additionally when we configure the
routing through these nat gateways we're
going to configure them all with an
equal priority and that's going to allow
us to leverage ecmp or equal cost multi
path routing which is going to
distribute our outbound traffic across
the aggregate bandwidth of all of these
nat instances so it becomes horizontally
scalable if you need more bandwidth to
egress the internet you just add
additional nat gateways with the same
priority
now what if we want connectivity not to
the internet but to resources that exist
on Prem so data center resources we want
to create connectivity between our V PC
and the data center
there's a number of ways to do it we've
got a VPN solution there layer 3 peering
solutions note there's no SLA for those
so in many cases we recommend the layer
to interconnect solutions and there's
this decision tree which can be useful
to help us evaluate which of these five
options are appropriate for us now on
the left-hand side of the decision tree
is where we're exploring the peering
options in many cases these are used in
cases where we want to establish low
latency interactions for the G suite ap
is for our end users of G suite Google
Docs and Google sheets so for purposes
of today's presentation we're really
going to focus more on the right-hand
side of this decision tree which is
going to help us decide well is cloud
VPN appropriate or maybe a full 10
gigabit dedicated interconnect or if we
don't need 10 gigabits of bandwidth
maybe just the fractional bandwidth of a
partner interconnect but we'll also see
momentarily how you might use some of
these together you might start with a
cloud VPN and then move to an
interconnect related solution and I'll
show you a kind of common pathway along
that journey from cloud VPN to to
interconnect so what is cloud VPN cloud
VPN is our IPSec connectivity option
where you create a cloud router and GCP
and a VPN gateway and then you configure
any number of tunnels between that VPN
gateway and your on-prem routers this
allows you to have RFC 1918 connectivity
it's encrypted
because of the IPSec and it also allows
you to provide resilience in your
environment because you can define
multiple tunnels if you have multiple
routers you can define the tunnel to
each you can also use ecmp again if you
need a higher bandwidth solution you can
expect between 1.5 and 3 gigabits per
tunnel
but if you need additional bandwidth you
can configure multiple tunnels with
equal priorities in their routing
configuration which will again cause our
routing to distribute the traffic across
the aggregate bandwidth of those tunnels
so the other option that we're going to
focus on here is dedicated interconnect
now this is a physical link in a Colo
facility where you have a router google
has a router we cross connect those
routers and you can get a full big 10
gigabit link between your environments
we've got dedicated internet connection
in our dedicated interconnect locations
around the globe
and you can check the website where you
know frequently adding additional
locations but remember we said that
interconnect is in many cases preferred
because there are supported
configurations with interconnect where
there's an availability SLA so let's
take a look at a couple of those
configuration options so this would be
the dedicated internet dedicated
interconnect configuration if you're
looking for three nines of availability
notice in green we've got your router in
the Colo facility blue we've got the the
Google router notice there are two links
not a single link because there's no SLA
for a single link configuration but
we've got two links configured there and
those two links have to fit specific
requirements there are two links that go
into separate physical zones within the
same Metro if you notice that those
dedicated interconnect locations were
defined in a metro area and we use those
metro areas for purposes of availability
planning like with maintenance cycles
and things like that so you would have a
link into two links into the same Metro
but in two different physical zones
within that Metro and that configuration
will give us three nines of availability
if we want to extend that beyond three
nines and we're interested in four nines
of availability
what we'd essentially do is duplicate
that configuration notice now what we've
done is introduced a secondary region so
we've got a similar configuration where
we've got multiple links into two
different physical zones in the same
metro but then we've doubled it in
another region two more links into two
different physical zones within a
different metro in a different region
and by configuring things that way
because of the additional geo redundancy
this configuration is supported with
four nines of availability in the SLA we
also discussed that path from VPN to
interconnect which is a common journey
many of our customers take because
sometimes when you're just starting out
with a proof-of-concept or early in the
project it's very easy to stand up a VPN
tunnel get that private connectivity
initially going but as that proceeds as
the initiative gains momentum as you're
formalizing your platform in many cases
you want to follow that up with
something like a dedicated interconnect
now it's it's this is going to show us a
way where you can do that in transition
seamlessly from a cloud VPN to a
dedicated interconnect what we've
basically set up here is a cloud VPN
it's pretty standard we've got a couple
of tunnels set up notice we're using
ecmp routing as we discussed the only
thing that's really unusual here is that
we've set our BGP med or the priority as
we call it to 100 instead of its default
value of 1,000 you'll see why that
matters when we bring the interconnect
on line when we bring the interconnect
on line we bring it online with its
default priority of 1000 so even as
those routes start to be advertised by
GCP the priority 100 routes are going to
be preferred so your traffic's still
going to be flowing over the VPN and
then when you're ready for the
interconnect solution to go live you
just reverse the priority values set the
VPN priority to a thousand set the
internet the interconnect priority to
one
hundred and by doing that now the
interconnect routes will be preferred at
that point you could potentially turn
the VPN solution off or in many cases
we'll see customers leave it there as a
backup a fail-safe it still works if
something happened to the interconnect
route the the cloud VPN routes would
then be able to service a traffic so
we've explored topology we've explored
connectivity we also want to explore
some of the security related foundations
in GCP one of the common resources that
we're going to use is our firewalls now
this slide is kind of showing us on the
left-hand side a traditional enterprise
model where you might have a firewall
appliance and you route traffic through
that appliance in the cloud we prefer
distributed systems we like to avoid
those kinds of choke points and single
points of failure so it's interesting in
GCP that firewalls are implemented as a
distributed system there's not a
firewall appliance you could run a
virtual appliance if you wanted that but
GCPs firewalls are distributed enforced
on the host based on rules that you
define and those rules allow you to
specify the source of the traffic the
destination of the traffic protocols and
ports allow or deny that traffic and
then target that rule to a specific
instance or set of instances there's a
couple of ways to do that could do that
you know all vm's in a network you could
do that with target tags tags or little
just text values that you tagged on to
the onto the instance so you could say
web server and use that web server to
target like a port 80 or 443 rule you
can also target service accounts
remember Ray introduced service accounts
as the identity that we specify when we
launched that virtual machine so that
virtual machine runs in the context of
that service account identity and we can
actually target fire
rules to that service account identity
over two instances running in that
service account identity and we'll see
on the next slide that's actually our
preferred way of targeting firewall
rules for the reason that tags are
mutable you can change the tags on an
instance and by changing the tags you're
potentially changing the firewall rules
that are being enforced on that instance
and if we want to be really sure that
the firewall rules are defined
appropriately and being used
appropriately in our environments if we
target service accounts instead surface
accounts have control in iam we can
specify which users are allowed to
launch instances in which specific
service accounts and service accounts
can't be changed on a running instance
in order to change the service account
you have to stop the instance first and
then start it again and for that reason
if we target our firewall rules to
service accounts we've got tighter
controls over the configuration of those
rules and who is allowed to say launch a
web server who is allowed to launch a
server you know according to other other
rules
this slide is introducing an alpha
feature you may or may not have heard of
it and there'll be some discussion of it
at some of the other breakout sessions
here next but this is firewall logging
so this is a feature that you can enable
per firewall rule and when it's enabled
firewall logging will create a record of
every decision when a connection is
either allowed or denied because of that
rule firewall logging is going to log
that decision and then you can define
filters that would select all or some of
those firewall logging records and
direct them to your to stackdriver
logging to pub/sub GCS big query
wherever you want those those logs to be
accumulated so this is a great way to
have visibility into the security
decisions that are being made within
this environment that you've defined
another logging feature that provides us
visibility into our BBC Network
environments is VPC flow logs now VPC
flow logs provide us a five-second
five-second aggregated report for each
what we call a five tuple flow the five
tuple is a way that we kind of uniquely
identify a flow of traffic that's a the
five tuple is the the source address and
port the destination address and port
and the protocol right and that five
tuple uniquely identifies the flow of
traffic
so for each five tuple flow every five
seconds you'll get a log record that
shows you the the bytes transfer the
packets additional annotations for the V
pcs and the geographic information of
that of that traffic and again you can
configure that using stag driver to
filter some or all of those records and
direct them to your appropriate
repository to keep those records
available for your analytics queries
one final feature that we'll discuss
again this is a feature that's in beta
private beta now and this is an
interesting way we talked before about
the idea of perimeters and as we begin
to sort of segment our environments and
think about security perimeters how do
we enforce those perimeters let's
imagine a scenario where we have created
a V PC Network we've got VM instances
running in that network and we've
allowed them to egress either via
private Google access or through NAT or
even with a public IP address we've
allowed them to egress and interact with
our Google API right so we've got VMs
running in the V PC and they can
interact with Google Cloud storage they
can write data into buckets read data
from buckets how do we know that the
buckets that those VMs are writing data
to are actually buckets that are owned
by our company right what's preventing
data exfiltration what's preventing a
rogue script from uploading data into
some bucket that's actually not owned by
our company that's what V PC Service
controls are for it allows us to define
a service perimeter and that service
perimeter is essentially a grouping of
resources including the the resources
running in our V PC the buckets and and
other GCP resources and it's only within
that service perimeter that resources
are allowed to interact so this would
for instance make sure that instances in
our V PC can interact only with
company-owned buckets and in fact
instances in other V pcs or traffic from
the Internet at large would not be able
to interact with those buckets because
that traffic comes from outside the
service perimeter but you can extend
that service perimeter if you do want to
extend it to allow traffic in from the
internet like for web serving scenarios
that's supported or if you want to
extend it even to your on-premises
network so your data center network can
become part of that service perimeter
that's supported as well
but this tool allows you to then draw
that boundary and create that collection
of resources and harden that that
perimeter and so this will be an
important new feature for our network
security
so hopefully that intro has given us a
feel for some of the design decisions
that we have to make and some of the
features and tools that we have in GCP
to help you create your network
foundations create your security
foundations now I want to turn the floor
over to my colleague more ghonte who's
going to show us how to automate some of
these deployments thank you awesome
thanks Jeff
so he's been a lot of time talking today
about how you can sip effective
organizational hierarchy and stuff your
network but maintaining this over time
can be a lot of work if you don't have
some automation in place it allows you
didn't force the best practices across
our organization so every time your
onboarding new users onboarding new
projects into GCP you can have that done
automatically and have your codified
best practices so putting your
automation in place gets all the
benefits if you're in source control you
can actually collaborate on it you can
have pull requests you can have
suggestions of changes to policies or
changes to your network topology all
collaborated through a pull request
instead of having to only have in
conversations or through manual actions
you also ensure consistency you can make
sure that every single project you're
quitting in GCP has the exact same
consistent settings the right subnets
the right IM permissions the right role
set up for that to find exactly in code
you can also reduce the manual effort
and so having a single person go in and
can provision any new service account or
our new service project you can just
have the code automatically do that in a
very consistent and automatable way and
then even enforce policies proactively
so if you're saying any of our dev
projects can only get access to the dev
VPC if that's coded into your modules
and into your infrastructures code you
can be confident that every time you're
creating those new projects they're not
accidentally getting access to networks
or resources they shouldn't have access
to so this is what one of the pipeline's
might look like you'd have a sort of
common modules or templates for what a
project looks like in your organization
or what a network or subnet looks like
an organization and you combine them
with configs specific to a particular
application use case
so you could have a for example
subnetwork that's that's defined every
time you're putting a subnetwork
for your dev testing that has had
certain names and then you would have to
have a service account that's according
the firewall rules and that can you can
ride together with the config specific
to the application so you take those the
configuration and the modules together
combine them into a plan and then take
that plan and deploy it assuming it
looks good to a non part environment to
a dev environment where you can actually
see it deployed Co crate we've got the
right resources we've got the right
project and then once it's looking good
you can actually deploy that same exact
code that same exact infrastructures
code and promote it into your production
environment so take that code and put it
the same way you have an application
release cycle you can have an
infrastructure release cycle so projects
and policies are some of the things that
benefit most from this right so if you
stay about projects in a very
standardized consistent way you can
minimize the proliferation of sensitive
owner roles so instead of having to have
individuals going and creating projects
in which case they by default get owner
on that new project you can have a
service account which is creating the
projects from code and make sure that
only people who actually need access the
project get access to it and by default
nothing besides the service account has
access to it you can also ensure that
you have access to shared resources like
the shared V PC or if you have a common
standardized image bucket where you are
have sort of less company's base images
you can make sure all new projects in
the services in those projects get
access to that and this can be automated
with deployment or terraform or our
public api's and your own tooling using
those public api's so for an example
flow for a new project might be create
the project let's create a Google App
Engine app in that project if your
company is using App Engine enable
billing on the project and associate
with the appropriate billing account
enable any allowed api's and only the
allowed api's on that project and then
create specific service accounts for
that project and then finally if you
actually want to have developers say be
able to only view the logs in that
project you could have the same project
factory process actually create set the
ion policies on the new project and give
the right people access to it so this is
sort of talking about so that
methodology of how your project is code
right it's the project's only
to the UI you can have actual process
where somebody wants a new project you
say that you have a new team that they
want to get access to GCP they're really
excited to start developing their code
what they would do is they could go to
the central projects repo where all the
projects that you want in GCP are listed
they'd make up their own branch make
some changes to add their own project
listed in there and then make a pull
request right that says I want to add
this project and then you can have some
automated tooling that first looks at
that pull request and says okay good
it's on the right subnet it has the
right configuration it looks good from
the automated ratio perspective and then
have a central team actually go in and
manually review that pull request make
sure that everything looks good there
right so you have both automated and the
manual sign up on it and then in what's
thought looks good
you actually merge that pull request
right and then once it's actually merged
into the master branch is when it
actually gets created from the service
account so no individuals are creating
projects it's always going through a
pipeline through code and if you want to
learn more about that we actually have a
section on Thursday that's actually
talking about how we apply those same
principles of policy as code to
kubernetes and taking those same
principles of a pull request workflow
for changing your policies so this works
really well for proactive defense right
if you have policies that are defined
through code and you're proactively
finding any problems as you're quitting
the infrastructure that's really great
right but there can be drift over time
people can have there might be some
legacy organization admins there might
be some different services running GCP
sometimes even changes or certain things
for your acting activating kubernetes
engine that will create some service
accounts on your project so you also
want to have reactive visibility and
detection of any problem any policy
violations that's way of a open source
tool called for study which can actually
do that violation detection
retrospectively it works by doing first
building inventory right so it has an
inventory of all the resources all the
way down to the individual VM or
firewall rule level within your entire
organization and takes that inventory
and can actually run policy analysis
over it so you can say all right here's
all the firewall rules in my
organization I should have no firewall
rules that target IP ranges because we
decided to have the best practice the
only firewall rules only target service
accounts right so you could have that as
one of your policy
and for study could flag any rule that
violates that policy and then in some
cases emote in all cases where there's a
policy violation would notify you so
notify administrators with an email but
all could also could actually even
automatically enforce that so bring it
back into a compliance state into
compliance with your code it could
policies in really effective way so that
we're sort of GCA firewalls and we're
adding more over time and there's also
for study section on Thursday if you
guys are interested in checking that out
and diving really deep into what for
study can do to help you have automated
Policy Analysis so we're talking a lot
about how you can automate all these
things together right obviously you know
Google will supports this we want you to
be able to have your infrastructure
defined in code which is why we have
Google deployment manager it's our
hosted native tool for creating an
infrastructure as code I mean we can
actually it's a hosted service right so
they're actually I for it similar to any
of our other projects you can go into
the cloud console and find information
about deployment manager see all of your
existing deployments and even see what
the status of those deployments is so
what resources they create what
configuration values are passionate to
those deployments and one thing that's
really cool at the point manager is it's
totally API driven it's not custom logic
for each individual API that's
integrated with its using the same
public API is that you see in our API
Doc's to actually call those services
the really big advantage that is when
you know you hear it next right you're
hearing about people coming out with new
features for all of our different
products all the time windows are added
to an existing API the client manager
can immediately get support for those
new features because it's just calling
the underlying API so if there's a new
property added to a particular API it'll
immediately be able to call that API and
get access so you're not being time buck
so you're not being having to wait for
the automation to catch up with where
you're at which is a huge benefit to
being able to adopt automation across
the board for all three infrastructure
and templates of course you know back to
our when we first started talking we
want to have these all be template eyes
you want to have things in a very
consistent way you're not custom writing
config for every single deployment you
want to do you want to have reasonable
templates across the company those can
be written in Python
so a really expressive full language
right you've got all the power of Python
to create your templates there's a blank
manager but if you want something a
little bit simpler
there's also ginger to templates which I
can show some examples up to here cool
so this is example of something
types that we have so on the left here
is if you want to do that sort of
project creation hierarchy right we were
talking about how you want to stamp out
products in a very consistent way this
is how you do it with a Python template
in deployment manager so notice here we
take in a couple parameters we take in a
project ID a project name and a folder
ID so we say we want to put this into
our dev folder for example and we want
to create that we can take those
parameters in and actually have a
deployment sure you through this common
template do the correct Association
create that project in the Krait folder
and actually even here it's at the end
it's a little bit cut off but you can
even do the billing accounts association
so create that project and then attach
it to the correct billing account for
that as part of that template now if you
go a little bit more advanced right
you're you know going really deep into
the service accounts and doing really
advanced custom roles and you know you
sort of pushing the box so you want to
make have a very clear definition of
what a service account what permissions
it is that you can start doing I on
custom roles so if you don't create a
custom role that can be done through the
UI but again we want to think about
things as policy and we want these cut
policy and code rights if it's in code
it's much easier to know what that role
is and change the permissions associated
that role over time so that's why on the
right here we have an example of a
ginger template for creating custom role
right where we take in some properties
within the curly braces there like a
role ID a title for their role some of
the permissions that are included in
that role all through the curly braces
there on the side right now what's
really cool about deployment manager
templates is we want them to reusable
right so you want to be able to switch
them between multiple contexts that's
why as you can see here there's the in
part right you can actually pick up the
current project from the current context
by referencing the env part there that
just allows you to take that same
template run it against different
projects and actually have the those
roles be created in the correct current
project so it allows a lot of
flexibility to actually have these
templates adapt over time so we've got a
lot of examples of these if you go on
github we've published dozens and we're
publishing more every day of samples of
how you can use deployment manager to
automate these things now Google of
course wants to make sure that we have a
hosted supported solution for this but
we also embrace the output source
community we know there's other tools
out there that can support all these
tools which is why we even have teams at
Google that work on maintaining really
strong support for the open source
tooling in GCP so Tara forms an example
that's where we
we want to make sure there's a really
strong integration between terraform and
GCP so that over time you can very
easily use tariffs on to define all of
your infrastructure and have it be
configured automatically so this is
example of how you could use a service
account credentials file so that's a
JSON credentials file that you download
from DCP to an authentic eight terraform
to access our API right and you can
forget a project that it's accessing
there and then down below we see an
example actually that how you create a
project in terraform right so you would
say this is the project D this is the
billing account ID that I want to attach
that project to an org ID and then a
name for that project and that can be
done very very easily in terraform and
one of my personal things I really like
to do is actually have bindings declared
in code so you don't have people going
manually and saying oh I want project
admin and somebody just does that
randomly and nobody even knows that they
granted that role you can actually do it
all through terraform code here we have
a Google project
I am binding saying the only people
defined in this role I'm in this case
Jane at example.com get the project
editor role on that project and so we've
done totally in code and one of the
things that this actually would do with
the project iron binding is wipe out any
other policies so if somebody went in
and mainly gave themselves editor but
they're not defining the code the next
time the code is run they'll that bond
will be removed right it makes sure that
only the people who are supposed to have
the role have the role and that you
always do it to the code instead of
doing it manually so one of the things
Jeff talked about was that really our
best practice for having secure firewall
rules is do them through service
accounts right you don't want to have
people going in and editing Network tags
and allowing their VM to egress wherever
it wants ingress wherever it wants you
want to have some security controls over
who can do certain firewall rules so
this is a end an example of how you
could do that right you could take a up
here in the top left you'd actually just
create the service account right you
give it an account ID and you give it a
display name for that service account
right and then down below you actually
do a binding of who can access that
service account who can take the service
account Act user role and is able to
launch VMs with that service account so
this is saying only our web app devs are
allowed to want launch service accounts
using the web app service account right
so they you know another team but is not
authorized to use that can't go and
click create VMs because they don't have
the service account user role on that
service account so this
access control of who can actually do it
and then finally you have the firewalled
rule to find to allow ingress on port 80
for that service account tricky lot of
flexibility that you know you don't want
anybody to be able open they're super
secure opportunity there VM up to the
Internet
you only want people who have that role
and have that binding defined be able to
actually allow internet ingress into
their net into their service so now I
just want to skip into a demo where we
can actually show you guys how some of
this works cool so here's my terraform
config we're using terraform today to
show us in the features I'm just want to
show how I actually have my a terraform
back-end state
stored in GCS and then here's how we
actually can define our whole resource
hierarchy within terraform right so we
want to have multiple folders in this
case we're doing a split between prod in
dev so you find our prod
and we define a dev folder down here and
then we have an existing folder maybe we
have a web team right they've got some
they've got all their dev resources
within that folder you can apply policy
to that folder now let's say we want to
add an additional folder just for our
demo today so you know we're doing some
demo at next 18 so how we could do you
know demo demo mode of 18 and we want to
keep it in the dev folder right so it's
still bring a nested folder underneath
the dev dev dev folder so that's gonna
you know this is all I need to do to add
a new folder it's all defined in code
and theoretically if this was a
production environment I'd be doing pull
requests for these parts right so I have
that folder created and then I actually
want to create a project within that
folder so this is where I take this sort
of standardized config that I have um so
this is a module that we've developed
for terraform that allows you to create
a project and attach it to a bunch of
resources and actually create a new one
so I'm gonna do you know in a new file
copy this over and customize it for my
new project so in this case I want to
you know call it let's say demo and I
want to call it you know our demo app
right just just for today
and then we want to put it in that new
folder that we created right so that
that folder was dev demo and then part
you often want to have groups right so
one of our best practice is to use
groups for access management and as part
of the standard tool you can actually
even create the groups for you and if
you didn't already have the tool if you
didn't already have the groups available
you want to you know get the initial
editors for this project in a group this
can actually even create that group for
you so we could say demo devs
and we're gonna give them the editor
role in the project we've got some sort
of configuration if you're like what
billing account to use our credentials
file to use for acquitting everything
and then even an API search account
group now myfirstproject only use
compute let's say I also want to use
pub/sub on this one so I just add pumps
up in here
right as an additional declaration and I
could only I could have exactly what API
is really accurate in the put on the new
project defined right here in my code
and then I finally shared you can see
right we talked a lot about how you want
to make sure it service accounts get
access the right shredder EPC so here I
specify you know which which product is
my shared with PC host right we were
this is a service project we're creating
and we want specify what the host
project is but then even down to the we
can have granularity done to subnet
levels so we don't need to share all the
subnets up from that house project we
just want to share let's say our US
central non frog Network or non project
right so this is finds that exactly that
subnet is shared and no other ones rave
mentioned labels as one of our really
effective mechanisms for getting an
additional granularity and info on how
your projects work so you can actually
specify some labels for this so let's
say it's you know demo app cool and then
this is all the config die need to do to
actually create that new project and
then I might want to actually add an
output just to you know get back the
project ID when I'm done so I could just
do you know demo
and demo here cool so we've got our new
config everything's looking good
presumably this would go through some
sort of marriage request process so I do
some pull request and then as part of
that pull request somebody would run a
terraform plan so you know I do
terraform plan so actually first let you
in it which will actually take care of
downloading the modules from github so
you saw that this one was actually
hosted on github so it'll go out
fetch the modules effects the providers
and actually pull everything in and then
I can actually plan it so this requires
a state lock checks everything that
currently exists right just doing a
bunch of checking right and then you can
see here's all the changes that we made
right I'm going to create a new project
right here's the new project that's
being created and do a bunch of other
things in process I'm going to create
the new folder right so they're to
create the folder before we create the
new project we have to attach that new
project to our shared VPC we have to
grant the new api service account so
google always has an api service account
associate with every project that is
used for anytime google so using on your
behalf so for example manage instance
group whenever we're in the manage
instance putting up new VMs we go
through the api service account that
google created and we want to associate
that to the VPC subnets so though anyone
that's shared we're gonna make sure the
group that has access to this project
also has access to use those subnets
that you're sharing to that project so
we do a role there and then we do a
service account role to VPC subnets so
we make sure that the service account
that's being created gets access to the
subnets uh being shared because there's
a lot of these different you know if you
want to have those two very granular
permissions you have to make sure that
you everything that needs to have access
subnets does have that level of access
and then as I mentioned you actually can
even have it this automation can even
create the G suite group for you so
it'll create a G suite group and give it
the editor role in that project and then
we it's going to you know to create a
default service account so you have one
source gun to get started with you could
add more service accounts into the
configuration if you wanted to and then
do some membership there so I'm just
going to go ahead and run this so just
do tariffs on apply
that's just running say yes and it's
gonna go ahead and create everything so
it does it figures out how to parse
things in real correct order so it knows
to actually create the folder before it
creates the new project because
obviously the folder has to exist for
the project to work and it's going ahead
and spending up spending everything up
overtime so it's putting the project
doing the subnet Association doing
everything there one thing I do want to
call out while it's doing that if
something that's pretty special about
how this works is it actually will take
that API service account and put it into
a group for you right because by default
service accounts you can have a
proliferation of many service accounts
within your organization right if you
every service of every project you
create has some service accounts and has
multiple service accounts for different
api's so there's a lot of benefits
actually having groups that group those
different service accounts together so
if you wanted to say say all my servers
that comes in the organization should
have to pull GCM GCE images from a
common project you can just give them a
role at the group level right so the
same when you talk about users being
roles service exams can also be placed
into groups so that's one thing this
does is it actually takes that newly
created service account and all the
service gaps on that project and puts
them to a group for easy administration
well so it takes a little while for this
to actually process everything so I'm
just gonna you know spin it up speed it
up a little bit
my magic little speed up and then out if
any here you can see we actually add
that output so for our new cert GCP
service account
GCB project you can actually see you
know GCP next 18 simple demo 18 that's
our new project was created if i want to
go over here into the projects hierarchy
I can actually go ahead and find my
folder right so next 18 dev demo 18 and
my app was created and we see it
actually even has asked to the shared
project shared networks right so that
did that shared web sees hashman
everything's ready to go and this team
is now on-boarded and ready to start
using GCP and the sort of standard
policy config standard project they have
all the research they need to start
doing forward cool
so that's the demo we have today I'll
welcome Peter mark up to pull this out
so just to reiterate kind of where we
started and where we began this talk I
showed you the this migration
methodology that we use with our
customers when we're trying to migrate
large scale environments and data
centers and so on from assess to
foundation deploy and optimize and we've
really zeroed in on the foundation side
and that's because I think it's so
important for for customers to actually
spend the time spend the energy focusing
on this part because really the amount
of time that you invest upfront in those
first two stages in particular when you
plan out find out everything that you
have you find out what you want to move
and then you create this foundation of
what you need to move to the cloud is so
important it really is such a metric for
success for the later stages of
migration we really feel it's worthwhile
spending time to focus in on this and
find out what you need to do and then
for us to come out here and do things
like this where we talk about what we
think are the best ways to do things
like this there are a couple of sessions
that might be interesting if you're
you'd like to see other sessions where
people talk about migrations they've
gone through these four sessions are to
come in the next couple of days
and I highly recommend them
unfortunately a couple of sessions have
already passed but all of our sessions
are gonna be on YouTube in a couple of
weeks these ones will be worth looking
up if you'd like to watch again other
people's stories about the things
they've done and in particular I think
the Velo strata session and the cloud
spring session those are both Google LED
sessions fellow strata we recently
acquired they do VM migrations and cloud
sprints is a program by our professional
services organization that comes into
customers who are beginning a migration
journey and so it helps them kick that
by creating a well secured agile best
practices cloud foundation and on that
note thank you very much and well all
four of us be happy to take questions
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]